[Musique]
[ __ ]
c'est assez courant d'air là partout la
pas d'où ça vient c'est relou
[Musique]
si je dis je veux deux croissants et
atar tarde pas trop cuit samedi les jets
pas de tartas batteux trouve que c'est
normal
excalibur h est passé d interférence
dans les feuilles des arbres
ça me fait ça depuis ce matin excuse-moi
loïc est ce que depuis là quelques jours
quelques heures depuis ce matin tu
n'entends pas comme des chuchotements
avec dédé souffle un peu partout dans le
cou d'échauffement qui dirait quoi par
des chuchotements qu'ils disent est ce
qu'il ya des burnous escaliers en
bureaux et cessa escaliers en dur
escaliers en bur
c'est sûr que ça dit escaliers ambulants
oui je l'entends depuis ce matin je suis
sûr escalier en bois oui ça diraient pas
genre excalibur escalibur comme le
[ __ ] de casse tête que tu dois
terminer que tout le monde me casse les
couilles mais ma boulangère je vais
acheter un steak à me demander ce
calibur ça en est où fabien olicard les
commentaires je reçois des messages sur
instagram juillet de frapper à la porte
ils font escale bershka les rires donc
si vous êtes termine tu as pris un
engagement fabien il faut terminer ce
qu'elle bien ok [ __ ] c'que alliant
burnes
je me suis donc engagé à la fin d'année
la vidéo forcé et contraint par mon ami
loïc ici présents à terminer ce
casse-tête en un seul tournage mais
blague à part je pense quand même que
ces jeunes parce que si on en a enlevé
une le reste quand même devraient suivre
même si ça paraît quand même pas si
simple mais bon on va voir quand même ce
qui va se passer
bon tu me suces quand même temps loïc
alors t'es gentil c'est que si cette
semaine qui commande à manger tu
commandes pour moi aussi assez logique
j'avais un peu tripatouiller pour voir
un peu ce qui allait se passer pour elle
que je détermine à peu près qui va être
la prochaine sur mon tableau de chasse
ah oui mon hypothèse de la dernière fois
c'était de peut-être faire la faire
descendre dans ce cas là on a peut-être
que je l'aide comment je peux le faire
descendre à oui c'est lui qui bloque
c'est lui qui bloque pour la descente
alors du coup non mais un petit boulot
là parce que sache quelles recrues les
jeux peut pas reculer à cause de lui ok
comment remettre un peu de temps mais
est-ce que vous avez vu que j'ai l'air
moins déprimés qu'à la fin de la
dernière vidéo ça t'a j'ai commencé j'ai
commandé des nouveaux casques est là
c'est parce qu'elle ignore mais ils ont
l'air chant mais aussi mois mais des
casse têtes on voit ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur peut être un peu plus léger
moins bien l'avancé mais à cause de lui
je peux pas
8les qu'est ce qui se passe dans sa vie
à lui qu'est ce qui se passe dans ma vie
ma vie à moi
jean-michel bout de bois géré je me suis
remis en cause un long voyage
mais j'ai fini par voir la lumière au
bout du tunnel j'ai perdu du bois j'ai
grandi j'ai trouvé ma voie
je suis devenu tuteur pour jeunes
pousses je les aide à grandir dans le
droit chemin
je suis enfin à ma place sacré avant
[Musique]
6h30
ok donc il faut être méthodologique et
donc soyez vous aussi méthodologique les
amis c'est à dire qu'en regardant la
vidéo sdi méthodologique leaké cette
vidéo déjà pour se tenir
et puis si vous n'êtes pas abonné
cliquez sur le bouton abonnés pour pas
rater les prochains casse tête
c'est gratuit de sabonnères bien je
voulais faire monter demi
si je fais ce qu'il bloque à 8000 bloc
cela comme ça oui si je peux le dessin
ok c'est lui je le remets la presse
comme ça ça va plus je peux sortir là
puisqu'il en fait je descende rien au
punch est grave
je viens de vous empêcher de descendre à
[ __ ] c'est le surf à chaud à ce point
c'est vraiment je pouvais sortir lâche
pas
c'est ce qu'il fait voilà qui fait que
la en temps normal j'ai rien qui bloque
les pld sang ok on en est à l'épée de
descendu louie j'ai réussi à descendre
l'épée volontairement
j'insiste sur le côté volontaire indien
je relève le menton c'est parce que
quand même tout ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant taxer les burons n'a pas été
franchement très volontaires mais plutôt
hasardeuse pour sortir cet orgue greffe
comme ça bien
il faut folle et j'ai eu très très peur
de ce que tu préfères
maintenant il faut réfléchir et pour ça
peut-être tu vas pouvoir faire une
accélération
non c'est une fille ce soir mais c'est
parce que je vais essayer de rien de
rien bouger et maintenant de bien
comprendre l'intérieur de ce cube
excalibur ok pour essayer de me dire ok
la prochaine pièce que je vais essayer
sortir ça va être si ou ça
[Musique]
on est en jeu
ah [ __ ] sac nicolas bouger comme ça
c'est à dire que j'étais la poussée
comme ça le chp et irène
oui oh [ __ ] ça me change tout ah ouais
ça m'ouvre des possibles de ouf aux
jeunes hommes enlevés
[Applaudissements]
en fait moi je voulais descendre les
paie pour la descente déjà pas à ce
point par descendre comme ça mais ce que
j'avais pas pris en compte c'est qu'une
fois qu'elle est descendue là je peux
aussi la bouger comme ça en fait tu vois
et du coup ça m'a permis d'avoir un cran
plus grand pour sortir lui est ce qu'on
peut mettre des notes entre bleus et
verts sur les blagues de loïc s'il vous
plaît ah ouais on a le bac est là
clairement quoi c'est ça c'est ou fin
parce que là je me dis avec ta ces deux
là oui oui mais vous voyez que je
voulais regarder le dessous quoi parce
que là du coup ça devient intéressant
un peu oui à la cfu de pouvoir voir
l'intérieur
il est extrêmement satisfaisant quand
avance par contre par contre je peux
plus remonté chez parce que j'ai merdé
repose et on va continuer dans la plaie
scheer nos maîtres pour réfléchir si lui
je pousse là
[Musique]
elle
lui qui prend à nana na na na na na
c'est plus c'est luce le centre jeu le
mec comme ça à mort que lui je le pousse
jusqu'au bout ça me permet de l'emmener
là il est tenu excalibur on voit ses
entrailles abattement plus tôt on enlève
et plus tard il va dire à bridas corp
gfr tac tac est ce que vous vous
souvenez de cette pièce depuis le la
première vidéo
je me disais l on peut trouver trop de
l'enlever je peux toujours pas de
l'enlever à elle est toujours bloqué de
la même manière au même endroit alors
que j'étais persuadé dans la première
vidéo c'était la première que jean les
bras là ça se joue au millimètre sur des
trucs c'est mais on se le fait à la
réflexion ce le fait bien on réfléchit
correctement et et on articule dans sa
tête ça tu m'agace un peu
si on est quel tout comme ça emmerde
ouais mais bon là je suis obligé parce
que tout est en train de m'embêter un
peu non c'est pas mal c'est pas mal pour
lui là parce que lui c'est peut-être
moyen de le libérer en fait c'est que ça
qui m'embête
[Musique]
que j'aie lui qui est le proche et si le
crocheter pas
je pourrais passer
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais voilà
allez moi qu'est-ce qui est la leur et
si fou plus que trois pièces non mine de
3 quelques quatre pièces dans cinq
pièces [ __ ] seul le fit dit clairement
jamais c'est possible et ce soit elle la
dernière parce que je vois pas comment
faire en fait ce soit c'est la suivante
le ces dernières semaines tout comme
celui des hommes pour les têtes les
machins les vidéos indique la nasa
je comprends pas vous voyez pas fallu
ramer ramer le casse-tête à la maison
allez allez allez ramener des casse tête
à la maison on était quatre à la maison
allez allez allez ramener le kst lt la
maison allez allez
a priori je veux pas l'enlever
si je suis pas sûr que tout film est
bien la question est est ce que je vais
pouvoir sortir parce que tu veux je pose
tout va sur ses pas sur des fois dans
les casses têtes qu'il ya des pièges à
la fin et a eu la chance que ça accroche
mondiale à la vache
la famille est derrière toi je ne sais
pas
[Musique]
non non si ça en fait ça va
oh my god
bien je te fais chevalier maintenant que
j'ai excalibur c'est vrai un rêve tout
cas ce que je te fais chevalier roire
fabien arthur fabien oui c'est moi
arthur ah oui hartley seulement de
bretagne oui au nom du stream du switch
et de la chaîne secondaire de best-of je
te fais chevalier de loi qu'à molle à
toi la terre des fous que tu pourras
conquérir et mené d'une main de maître
merci pour ceux qui comprennent rien
c'est parce que vraiment on twitch
ensemble les lundis à 19h vous avez la
chaîne switch de loïc est la mienne dans
la description et on met des best-of sur
une chaîne secondaire qui s'appelle sur
le nom buju mais le lien dans la
description
voilà venez nous voir sur six être assez
bien c'est un mois de ce tracé les deux
seuls fou
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi ces trois
vidéos excalibur vous vous dites mais là
il faut qu'il refasse ses morts je ne
vais pas le requièrent c'est pas parce
que j'ai la flemme ou j'ai peur c'est
parce que c'est vraiment un trophée que
je vais mettre dans ce décor à compter
de beaufort à compter d'aujourd'hui
à compter d'aujourd'hui je le garde en
trophée évidemment j'aurais pu refaire
le casse-tête en franchement max 3 4
semaines
donc j'aurais pu le faire sans problème
mais je préfère le garder un trophée je
ne ferai pas pour une fois gagné ce
casse-tête sur instagram parce que je
veux le garder
ils meurent à trophées lutter trophée
galéré c'est je laime voilà c'est mon
trophée
dis-moi loïc maintenant j'ai l'épée
sacrée j'ai la cdp elle m'a choisie moi
j'ai le pouvoir elle protège ça c'est
mon anglais avait mon bouclier en même
temps qu'est ce que tu vas faire
maintenant ben moi je sais pas mais toi
tu vas aller bosser
rien de protéger du tout toi tu es un
allume feu pour cet été
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo laisse
airlines ici je vous mets deux autres
casse tête qui devrais je pense vraiment
plaire ça c'est un conte a résolu à deux
et ça c'est un coup seul c'est moi et en
plus c'est un des derniers il n'a pas
faire ses débuts par rapport à ce qu'ils
écoulent donc regarder le moi je vous
dis à très bientôt abonnez-vous cha
allah mois